I grabbed all of this will you met oh no
sorry just for five minutes till my
friends get you come on it's just I
don't really want to be too visible was
it your first bride their first anything
yeah well this is the best way you
looking for yourself in the thing is is
I'm actually from Brahminical don't
worry about that or a broadchurch no I
mean it's the Train it's further out
than people think at home I've been
dragging this thing on wheels it's
Marble Arch from one of their buckets
now you have to ask that question Mike
coming from Accrington Mike so you can
get rid of love by Joel where's mark
no let's end up everyone where exactly
of you be I want everyone to take a
pocket and start rattling this is for
the miners miners we agreed of a banner
mark it's a short solidary who hates the
miners Patra who else the police the
public and the tabloid press it sounds
familiar
surely the only problem we've got that
they haven't is marrying white hearts
and that will be a matter of time I know
it's not been planned it's not been
thought through but it's a really good
idea isn't it I think that
what we're supposed to do with a give it
to the lesbians they love about Oh for
god sake right looks like you're off the
op man for love whatever mark says we do
it your ass you are